HON NEWLEDOCK IALLY LIFESAVING
SAYS HAS NOT COMPLETELY  THE CYR
THEY'RE BUILDIP  EXTENSIVE
SYSTF TRENCHES I
>> THERE HEE EI
ARY NETWORPOSSIBLY ACCORDING T
BRH  REPORT THE
LARGEST WE'VE SE SINCE WORLD
R II ACROSS THE SOUTHERNREOF VA
ALTHE UCRAYIAN SIDE OF IT
FOR QUITE A PAUMBER OF WEEKS
HERE.OFNCHES
BACK BACKEY RAZOR WIRENDTHESE DD
COMPLEX Y E.FORM
PROBABLYN YS IF IN THE F UKRAINY
BEGIN THE COUNTEOF DAY
EA
Y DON'T  FULHE
R IS
POTENTIALLY PLG E'S BEVIDEOS F
MILITARY OVER THE PAST WEEKSTHR
BU HAVE SEEN HAVE
MOVE AROUND THLEAN ADVERTISED.
O FROM THE UKRAINIANO THE UNITEM
INT THIS BAD WEATHER IS
PLING .E  RAINY TNTE
FROM AROUND THE CITY OF BAKHMUT
SYMBOLIC THAT RUSSIAN
FORC TRESSING
LACK OFIGHAVE TO STARPULLING
BACK.
TE UTHAT.OTAGE  OCCUPIED AREAS S
THISADER ANTICIPATION OFHE
COUNTER OFFENS
OFAC YT TON OCCUPIEDASND ENEMY
GET CIOR L AHEAD.
AGO WD OFLICE OFFICIATHFOR THR.
KILLED ACCORDING TO
URERE, AND IN ST
S TEMPT TO TARGET AN
OR THE
PYING RUSSIAN FORCES THERE
WELL. TOP OF THAT, TOO, A
NUOSNS TARGEAC THAT AREAE MAY H
EXPLOSIVE VI, ES
ANOTHEPON JUST
IO Y BELIEVE IS THE OF UKRAINE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THEY LL NOT
ANNOUNCE, WE'RE SEEING MORE
GE AROUNIN
CARTHYER A.N WA.Y SOMEOR
CARTHY PUSHED BACK AGAINST A
T NOO N REPORTER WHO ASKED
UKRAKE
I RT WHAT YOURUKRAINSUR UKRAINE.
COUNTRY HA T
NOT SUPPORT YOUR KILLING OF
THE IL
ANK FOR E STANDPOINT
AND I DINK IT
>> THIS AFTER McHYRED ,
CH
GLAD TO HEARcCARTH DOWN EN
THAT.
ADVOCACY GROUPS CONTINUE
THE R FAMIESE
GNILIGILWASHINGTONC.S EVENING TI
ADMIRAO DO MORE TOIN DETAINEICS
THE WORLHO
AHEAD OF THE A BILLBOARD
TRD MESSAGES SUCASE PRESIDENT OF
SP
ONE OF THE US
TONIS VIGID,
EPIT R AIS JOINSS  THINK VKNOW G
WE GET TO
TONIGHT'S VIGIL FORRA
YEAR AGORELEASED FROM  PSO
I WANT TUR
CONVSA LEY TOL I
THOUG
AVG WHEN I
T IT CHOICE,TREVOR.
YOU DIDN'TE A CHOIE'S NOTHIND D.
>> Y TTHATD ATLD HAVE GOTTEN HI
WE GET HIM OUTANSTL,E FACT THATA
INVOLVED STILL ON TRYING TO GE
OTHER PELEUT IS
AL ER EVAN MENT CTY.T HERE W, P
IF YOU COULD SPERE WOULD YOU TH?
WOULD TELL THEMTHHAAND THU  H
WE'RP  CO NOT GIVE O E.
>> YOU?
EVERYTHING?N O PRISON.
>> Y>>A UP F , BU AFTER
B
FITTING BACK IN NGS
SO --  THAT'S GOOD., U  AND YOU
PARENTS LOOK TEN YEARS YOUNGER
THHETIME THEM.
>> OH,HA-UP.
>> NO, IT'
SO JOEY PAE BRING OUR OM IS TO T
NOT JUST THE ONES THAT ARE QUJU
E ONESARNOTABLE.WANT T AOFOSTAGE
RS
>> OF TH T S AINE
THOSE FAMILIH THPRESIDENT.
SO THERE W MAJORHT HOMIN LASWO
NEVER MET WIHE O
THE UNITED STATES.
,  THE.S. SOIL
>>ND VING ARMSHEIRHEC
BIDEN, ALL P HIM THE TIM SFAMIL
DED TOE
WISINT
AL
DIFFERENCE?
BERET ETT NEEDUBT. HAL
TOGHEAUCRACY
ABOUT OUSOALWHAT HE'S H, THAT HE
WILL ME
AND 27 DAYS LATE
THR NIGHYITALKINOU ISSUE.
IGD THE THING WAS LIKEPL
WE WEREN'TULARPLE.
NEVER LET , AN
GOING AND GOING AND GOING.
AND AFTER THATAP
BEESIDENT ISATE PERSON, HE COUL
PAIN IR FAMIT HAVING TO OUT IT
INK IT MADE A
DIFFERENCEIT WHESAYING, WELLN'T
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYING JUS
THIS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
TH AOL BINATION OF
THAT PERSONNEL ISSUE WITTH
DTH WERE
HERE TO IMPLORPRESIDENT TO, WIT
FAMILIESECIALLY THE ONES
THAT AREE IN MEAN THAND IT
D UGH IT WOULD
NOT BE INDIVIDUAL BUT EVENMINUT
THE POUCEE THAM.
WOULDEAT THING FOR E PRESIDENT.
I KNOW HE'D LOVE TO  IT,
NOTHING ELSE BUT ->> TREVOR, YO
DETAIN
U THINK?AT U RNET  RSCHKO.T  I
>> WN
ESCALATE THE
POINT WHERE THEY'RE U KNOW, R T
DED  THA OTO  GRAVEGEG, HOSTAGE
ANS G TO
CONTINUE TO MOUNT UNTIL, YOU
KNOW, EVENTU MAYBE
DIPLOMATS ARE GOING TO
TH T OF ALE
AMERICANS HELD AND DETAINED UNF.
ONE OF THET,O TH THREE, YOU'RE
NU
DO IT BECAUSE  MEANS A